Thank you. Very happy to be with you all
today. It's obvious there's going to be
a lot of moving back and forth in this
um event because we're talking about
different things. And it's called
Tradfest, which I assume means
tradition. And I'm going to be talking
to you about a very ancient and old
tradition amongst Christians which has
been forgotten and which is essentially
defending the faith. And to understand
it, we really have to go back in time in
history and talk about uh Christ
Christianity, Christendom's original
chief nemesis, which many people have
forgot, which really was Islam, believe
it or not. And I know this sounds hard,
and I'm going to try to give you the
receipts, as they say. Uh I know this
sounds difficult to believe for many
people because you've been told the
exact opposite for most of your life,
depending on your age, probably. And um
a lot of that has to do with the fact uh
that as we're talking and based on
tradfest the idea of Christianity sort
of receding going in the background
losing faith in itself which is to say
Christians losing faith in themselves um
all of that has created various
symptoms. So to me the rise and return
of Islam is very much um symbiotically
connected to the recession and the
weakening of Christianity. And you I
think you'll see what I mean when I get
done talking a little bit about this
this particular tradition that we
obviously have forgotten and which is
needed in many ways not just as physical
defense which is what I'm going to
primarily be focusing on but a spiritual
defense cultural civilizational defense.
All of these have really collapsed it
seems in recent years and decades and
that's why what's happening is
happening. It's really interesting to
note that the West is actually so much
more powerful than let's say the Islamic
world and yet at the same time it is
suffering from it constantly. Okay? And
that doesn't make any sense. So that's
just preliminary thoughts. Let's for
starters clarify history cuz like I said
this is my primary field. It really
surprises me to see how often it's the
exact opposite and I'll tell you how it
became the exact opposite. So the
tradition of Islam in the West, let's go
back in time. Islam according to the
traditional rendering basically starts
in the year 622 with Muhammad in Arabia
and he preaches I'm sure you know jihad
which gets translated as holy war and
already the confusion starts because
you've been hearing no jihad means
something else it means fighting the
self you know but no it was actually
holy war that was the exact and only way
it was understood and right from the
beginning after it after Arabia was
consolidated most people don't know this
but if you talked about the Christian
world at the time of Muhammad in the 7th
century, the majority of it is in those
countries which we today call the Muslim
world. Okay, so that would be all of
North Africa from Egypt in the east all
the way to Morocco, Libya, Algeria,
Tunisia and the Middle East. Okay, which
would be the modern states of Syria,
Lebanon, Israel, PA territories, Jordan,
Iraq, and of course Asia Minor, which is
what we call Turkey. So, not only were
those regions Christian, they were
actually more Christian than Europe in
the 7th century. Okay? And people are
not aware of this. It's kind of
interesting because they seem to think
those areas were somehow always Islamic
and if not Islamic, somehow eastern and
different. No, there was actually a deep
continuity between the North Africa and
the and what we call the Middle East and
Europe. Okay? The Mediterranean was
known as a Roman lake at that time.
Egypt for example for almost a thousand
years was hellenistic with Greek being
the primary language. When you talk
about a lot of the church fathers who
are Greek a great majority of them are
actually from Egypt and from Syria of
course Asia Minor. St. Augustine who's
uh apparently the father of western
theology was really a Berber from
Tunisia. So keep that in mind. That's
what the world looked like. That's what
the Christian world looked like in the
7th century. And keep it in mind also
because there's a lesson there that
something that was so profoundly
Christian could become what it is today,
the heart of the Islamic world. So how
did that happen? Well, it happened
through violence, conquest. And long
story short, this is my field. I've
written books about this if you're
interested, but I'm giving you the
digested version. So from the year of
Muhammad's death in 632 to 732, which is
the year of the battle of Ts in Portier
in the middle of France, that whole
region got conquered. that ancient
Christian region as well as Spain. Okay,
Spain of course another older Christian
territory and so at that point you have
Islam all in all that area conquering in
France now and then you get various
emanations of this. So this is the first
wave but then other waves come and other
peoples become Muslims. So the originals
are the Arabs and then later on you get
the Turks and they become the new
standardbearers basically of the jihad.
And if you really look at the text the
way I have um including in the original
sources and languages, this was really
seen as a jihad. Today they'll
historians who talk about these battles
and wars. They'll talk about Arabs and
Turks and Mongols, Tatars, Berbers, Mo,
but they don't really tell you the
overarching glue that propelled all
these people, which was they saw
themselves first and foremost as
Muslims. And they thought this was their
holy holy duty, which it was in Islam,
jihad, bringing Islam and Islamic
control all around the world. So that
happens and that goes on and then the
rise of the Turks come. Then you get all
of Asia Minor gets conquered. Okay? So
now we're talking literally threearters
of what was once the Christian world is
now conquered and absorbed.
Uh Europe the West really became what it
known known as the west because it was
the western most appendage of all that
Christian world that that was conquered
and it really became a final bastion of
Christianity. It had to fight to the
death otherwise it would have been
snuffed out and conquered just like the
rest. And this is interesting because we
come to the concept of warfare and
Christianity because there's apparently
nowadays a lot of people I use this word
I call it doormat Christianity and it's
to me it's the prevalent form of
Christianity in the west which is
basically if you want to be a good
Christian then you just behave like a
doormat and you never challenge anyone.
You don't stand in anyone's way. You
don't judge. You don't condemn. uh
you're a doormat. Okay. Well, that
doesn't seem to me to be how Jesus
behaved because he also whipped people
and hurled tables. So, there's
definitely a time for everything. A time
for war and a time for peace as the
Bible itself says. But the Christians
had no compunction at this point
fighting back and they did. And they did
it again in the concept of just war
theory which I won't get into but of
course that's has the deepest roots in
the Catholic tradition as we know and it
is in fact just but you know to just
give you an idea of how horrific this
sort of thing is and the lies if you
look at Spain today the way it's taught
in colleges you will hear about the
golden age and how Islam brought
knowledge and wonders and technology and
and all this sort of thing. much better
historians than who are from Spain have
written books in Spanish and in
Portuguese completely debunking this and
showing you that in fact what what Spain
was was essentially a microcosm of what
I just described which is the long
Islamic war on essentially Christian
nations. So if you look at that country
literally after it got conquered in the
year 7-Eleven as part of that long
continuum I told you about before they
entered in France it took it centuries 7
to 800 years fighting Muslims back
because after the Iberian Peninsula fell
a few Christians were holed up in the
northwest quadrant of the peninsula and
from there the reconista began and that
literally took seven centuries of
extreme bloodshed violence think about
ISIS pyramids of heads crucifixion
Christians. That was what was going on.
That's what the Muslims were doing
against the Christians as they tried to
reassert and reclaim their territory.
And again, to really emphasize to you
just how warped things have become, that
same nation now, Spain, after having
spent seven centuries of this, last I
heard is they just gave a blanket check
to like 500,000 or a million migrants
from Africa. Okay? So clearly we can say
those who don't learn from history are
doomed to repeat it in very graphic
ways. All right? But also it's important
to note and to emphasize that during the
this long war that what went on from
Islam against Christianity with and the
only rebuttal really is the first
crusade which people are so freaked out
about but um to give you an idea that it
also had hostility for Christianity. So
again, this wasn't just warfare to
conquer and you know whatever you can
have your religion. No, this was very
much rooted to Islamic doctrine and
teaching which is about subjugating the
other and putting them in their place.
All throughout these centuries that I'm
discussing, wherever the Muslims would
conquer a Christian region, it would be
very hard for the course for churches to
be attacked and destroyed. The nice ones
would be transformed into mosques. Okay?
Christians would be killed
half-hazardly, especially if they dared
resist. women and children abducted,
enslaved, raped. Okay, what I described
is normal warfare attack on people. It
was always there because there was
always this thing about desecrating
churches and statues of Jesus and
breaking crosses and all that sort of
thing. It's from the beginning all the
way on to well up until we saw with ISIS
and groups like that. But to give you
one idea, in the year 1009, the Fatimik
Fatimid Khalif Hakimah who's based in
Egypt destroyed according to the Muslim
source historian El Maki 30,000 churches
in in Egypt and Syria, which on the one
hand again underscores just how
profoundly Christian that region was
before Islam did what it did and also
how bad the persecution was. He also
destroyed the Holy Sephiler Church. Not
a lot of people know that, but the
original one was destroyed by him. And
then a smaller one was rebuilt. And then
that one started to be attacked as well
in that same century, the 11th century,
which finally led to the first crusade.
And right before the first crusade, the
Turks were running a muk and especially
in Asia Minor. And the sources I've
looked at, especially Armenians, we know
about the Armenian genocide. In fact,
yesterday was uh I think the Armenian
genocide remembrance day. But most
people don't know that the genocide
really began a thousand years ago at the
hands of the Turks when they started
pouring into greater Armenia and East
Asia Minor and all the way up into the
west. And according to the sources such
as Matthew Adessa who was a contemporary
literally tens of thousands of
Christians were being butchered many
more enslaved. One city Ani uh I think
it was the capital at the time was known
as a city of a thousand and one
churches. Each church was systematically
desecrated and destroyed and a lot of
them most of them actually burned to the
ground. So the point is that it's not
just this this is an ancient foe who
isn't just attacking for property or for
material reasons. It's for idealistic
religious reasons as well. Okay. The
Quran for all the talk that there's, you
know, some sort of connection or
brotherly love that can occur between
Muslims and Christians, it flat out says
it denies the Trinity. It flat out says
that they who who believe Jesus is the
son of God are infidels.
And if you are that, well, according to
Islam, you should either be killed or
subjugated or forced into Islam. That is
exactly what it says. You can see Quran
9:5. Quran 9:29 says to fight
Christians, people of the book, Jews as
well, until they pay tribute and feel
themselves subdued and oppressed as
secondass citizens. And there's a whole
long tradition of all that sort of
thing. So the point is the war was
ongoing. non-stop. It had all sorts of
different manifestations. The
Mediterranean islands were of course all
conquered in this early stage. earlier
historians such as uh Henry Pyin, French
historian Pyin, he wrote um Charlemagne
and Muhammad and his thesis was very
interesting because he basically traced
and said the dark ages was a complete
product of Islam which makes absolute
sense because what I just told you this
mass sundering of Christendom in half by
swallowing up the southern half south of
the Mediterranean created a massive
trauma basically for Europe which was
now like the little brother, the little
Christian left on its own okay which had
just recently been few centuries earlier
conquered by barbarians who had by this
time of course been Christian so that's
according to his thesis which was very
popular but has also been suppressed
later in later years that is what caused
the dark ages so interesting that Islam
had created the dark ages but then it's
hard to even stop because I'm giving you
just randomly different episodes of
violence by Muslims but there was also
the slave trade and this was one of the
more famous because we have good
documentation is barbar Barbrey would be
North Africa, Algeria, these nations.
They were Muslims and they thrived
exclusively on enslaving Christians,
Europeans, and they went everywhere as
far as Iceland. So, no one was too
distant or too remote for them to get
to. They went to Iceland and came back
with hundreds of slaves. We know at
least one time also in Ireland um and
other different regions. And we also
know for a fact that in the 16th century
they had 1.25 25 million slaves from
Europe. Okay, we don't we don't hear
about that for some reason when we hear
about slavery, which is a little odd.
And then of course I you know I've left
the best for last cuz you all know it,
the the Ottomans and the Balkans. Uh so
I won't wax too much on that, but that
would be probably the most ferocious,
the longest lived because the the rise
of the Ottomans is um you know early
1400s, late 1300s actually with Usman.
It goes on and on and the wars and the
annexation, the fall of Constantinople
in 1453. Of course, that's the most
iconic moment of this massive jihad, but
of course there's all sorts of other
battles. Croatia of course knows its
role holding the line as well being at
this, you know, crack fault with the
Ottomans on one side and all these wars
which go on incidentally speaking of the
Ottomans, their high point is in the
year 1683. So I already told you, you
know, the fall of Constantinople 1453.
So this is now well over 200 years later
and now they're surrounding Vienna.
Okay, that's how far they've gone. So
imagine all these areas I'm telling you
about the map. All of North Africa, all
of the Middle East, Asia Minor, all of
which were Christian, Spain conquered
into France, and then now they're in
Vienna. Okay, so I've actually put
together a map and if you look at it and
I colored the areas that were attacked,
it's almost all of Europe was attacked.
Rome was attacked in 846 by Sariss
pirates from North Africa. Okay. So, no
one really escaped. It was always seen
as ideological. Just to really emphasize
it, even the United States of America's
very first war as a nation after it had
gained independence from Britain was
with Muslims acting the same way and
saying the same things. I'm talking
about the Barbar Wars. Again, the same
fellows that were enslaving Europeans in
almost in the late 1700s after
independence. They started attacking
American vessels and sailors, enslaving
them, torturing them, doing horrific
things to them. And then finally, we
have a very telling letter, which I
enjoy quoting at length by Thomas
Jefferson, the United States third
president and author of the Declaration
of Independence, the paragon of
enlightenment. So he and uh John Adams
met with one of Barbar's ambassadors, a
Muslim man by the name of Abdul or
Abdullah.
And then Jefferson wrote in a letter to
Congress what came of their parlay, what
came of their meeting. Uh Jefferson of
course is trying to recover the enslaved
Americans and also put an end to
hostilities. Okay. So Jefferson writes
to Congress the following quote. We took
the liberty to make some inquiries
concerning the grounds of their
barbberies pretensions to make war upon
nations who had done them no injury. And
we observed that we considered all
mankind as our friends who had done us
no wrong nor had given us any
provocation. So basically Jefferson just
said, you know, let's be friends. We
we're we're open to working with you.
There's no need for this hostility. Now
look look at what the ambassador told
him. He continues, Jefferson, quote,
"The ambassador answered us that it was
founded on the laws of their prophets,
that it was written in their Quran, that
all nations who should not have
acknowledged their authority were
sinners, that it was their right and
duty to make war upon them wherever they
could be found, and to make slaves of
all they could take as prisoners, and
that every Muslim who should be slain in
battle was sure to go to paradise." And
this is in a letter we have March 28,
1786.
Now, isn't that remarkable? That sounds
like ISIS. It sounds like a radical
Muslims, the ones that don't represent
Islam, right? And yet here, this guy is
saying exactly what they said. And I
could tell you also all the earlier
attacks that I mentioned all throughout
Europe and in the Middle East and North
Africa were again justified by this same
rationale that our Quran, our prophet
command us to do this. You're the enemy
and this is how it has to be. Okay. And
now really to underscore the role of the
tradition of fighting Islam that was
amongst the west and how it was a life
or death kind of thing. And speaking of
American presidents, I just gave you
Jefferson. Now let me give you Theodore
Roosevelt, Teddy Roosevelt, who was the
26th president of the United States and
a very well and accomplished historian
himself. Uh he died around 1919. But
look at what he wrote. quote,
"Christianity was saved in Europe solely
because the peoples of Europe fought. If
the peoples of Europe in the seventh and
eighth centuries and on up to and
including the 17th century, so for a
thousand years, had not possessed a
military equality with and gradually a
growing superiority over the Muhammadans
who invaded Europe, Europe would at this
moment be Muhammadan and the Christian
religion would be exterminated. Wherever
the Muhammadans have had complete sway,
wherever the Christians have been unable
to resist them by the sword,
Christianity has ultimately disappeared.
That's a very accurate way to put it. Of
course, you won't find presidents
talking this way anymore because they're
politically correct. But that in a
nutshell is really the story of Islam
and the West that it basically grew as a
hostile movement really in
contradistinction to Christian
principles. One could argue that its
warfare always was underscored by
religious hostility and it was expressed
itself in the ways that I told you
including destru destruction of
churches, subjugation of Christians,
mockery of their icons and symbols and
that sort of thing. And it went on in
perpetuity. Okay. And uh it was only
because it's ironic to me because what
we call the colonial era if you talk now
I don't know about here but in the
United States if you talk about Muslims
have grievances the whole world has
grievances because of the colonial era
because of what Europeans did because
they entered into Africa Asia and they
just they they killed everyone and they
were horrible and so forth. What's
interesting and what's missing from this
is if you really look at the colonial
era it really partial parts of it
started again in response to Muslims.
France when it started going into
Algeria, it was because of the Algerian
slave trade and the Muslims there who
were, as I was telling you, enslaving
vessels, including the United States and
so forth. So that's what brought it into
a lot of Europeans back in that day,
they didn't they weren't necessarily
crusaders, but they understood the old
logic that, you know, we're fighting
back and they also knew this was
formerly Christian territory. Okay, so
that was what happened. And believe it
or not, if you look at the colonial era,
it's not that now they tell you that's
what Muslims are upset about. It's
actually the opposite. During the
colonial era is when Muslims more or
less lost faith in Islam and became if
you want if you want westward looking.
And you can see this the perfect example
is what happened in Turkey. Ottoman
Turkey, which as I said was the scourge
of Europe for centuries, was the first
one to turn its back on religion,
jettison Islam, adopt the Roman
alphabet, get rid of the Arabic alphabet
and become highly secular under aurk.
Why is that? Well, because I think from
the start the Muslim peoples gravitate
towards this creed because it's the
strong horse as they say and people want
to follow the strong horse. But when
they realized it wasn't and the West was
actually assertive and confident in its
ways and coming in and taking over and
bringing with it all sorts of booms and
technology and medicine learning, they
started, you know, despite themselves
losing faith in Islam. Many people don't
realize this because we get a different
narrative. We're told that they actually
this is when they were upset. That's the
new narrative. It's actually now the
opposite. You you know when Muslims
start to turn back towards Islam, it's
when the West actually loses its own
faith in itself. I give it the loose
time I'd say in the 1960s. All right.
With the rise of that sort of mentality
and permissiveness and decline of
Christianity. That's when you find
Muslims very much are actually they grow
disgusted of Western culture. One of the
prime examples is Seut an Egyptian. He
became the Muslim Brotherhood's uh chief
theoretician and um he went to America
in the 1950s to learn and he was
flabbergasted and shocked to see men and
women consorting okay by 50s standards
and uh so he he was one of many who came
up with the idea that these western
people we can appropriate and learn from
them technology and science and whatever
but we want nothing to do with our
culture it's corrupt it's depraved so
what happened they fell back on Islam
okay and Islam became the default so we
use their science and technology but we
govern ourselves culturally,
civilizationally according to Islamic
principles. Um so that's the story of
Islam in the west. That is the old
ancient tradition
between these two groups. One was
violent, one conquered, one actually
fought back, did the best it could and
eventually prevailed. And now Islam is
coming back in the guise of let's say
Muslim migration in Europe which is a
major issue especially in the western
Europe. Of course nations like France
and the UK, Germany but other countries
as well are getting these large numbers
of Muslim migrants. Many of them come
bringing the sorts of mentality okay
you're the infidel I you exist for me to
plunder, rape, do whatever. So we see
that is happening and uh you know but
the bottom line is you have to
understand the difference and this is
what I was trying to say earlier is uh a
lot of people it's very common nowadays
to say Muslims are invading Europe well
no that is absolutely incorrect they're
not in being they're not invading
they're being invited that's the
difference the history I told you about
Europeans did everything they could to
fight back now this is what I was saying
now Europe is much more powerful than
the Islamic world technologically econ
economically, even militarily. So why is
it losing? Back when the times that I
was telling you about, including the
Crusades and before the Crusades, Europe
was actually the weaker compared to the
massive Muslim world, but it really
fought to the death to continue. Now
it's so powerful, but it's being
terrorized because it can't even create
policies that are rational. And so I
think that really sums it up in the end,
which is that basically
because West the West has lost its
purpose. I mean, look at what we we call
it in the west. What other civilization
is known by a a direction, you know?
We're not we don't really have much of
an identity. We're a direction. Okay,
then it's not something to fight and die
for, is it? A direction. Um there's
Islamic civilization, there's Hindu
civilization, Chinese, but then there's
the West, which is very interesting in
and of itself. So I think until such
time that the west manages to reassert
its Christian identity publicly
especially not just privately and um
also reject this um fabricated
historical amnesia. Okay, because like I
said those who forget history are
certainly doomed to repeat it and that
is in fact what's happening in Europe.
And of course most importantly to defend
free speech on these topics. Okay, this
is not hate speech. The new game is when
someone like me talks and about what I'm
talking about. I'm just giving you
historical facts. To call it hate speech
is just a very cynical way of just
shutting it down. And people should
definitely be cognizant about that. And
the bottom line is civilizations that
believe in themselves which in this case
actually Islam does survive and those
that don't well they disappear. So I
think it's time to resuscitate the
traditional way of the Christian world.
Thank you.
Bring back the fight.
Bring back the flame.
Bring back the fire and the rightous
name.